Hello and welcome to this short video on setup for the Python integration program.
In this we're just going to make sure that we've got the project running and that everything is
installed accordingly. So once you've downloaded the files and unzipped it,
you're going to see that you have three different directories in here. So the first one
215.00py. This one is the actual project files. The other two, one of them is going to be a lot
of the Python code which comes with the project and one of the libraries we will be using PyCache.
The other one is going to be some FBXs that we're going to use to demonstrate importing
assets into the engine. Now once you've opened up the project, come in and just click on 21.
This project is written in Unreal Engine 5.5 but it will probably work in future versions.
Might have to right-hand click and switch the Unreal Engine version. Once you've opened up
the project you should hopefully get something that looks a little bit like this. Now the only
thing that might be different is you can see that we have this little window here called
Teaching Aid. Now this might be a free-floating window. What I've done is I've dragged it up
into the corner here and docked it and moved it up just so I can see this top section here.
This is just a small tool that allows us to move within the project and swap over
the content drawer just so that we can make sure that we're all looking at
exactly the same things when we're doing these small exercises. The other thing I'd
like to mention while I'm in this is how you make sure your project is running and using Python
correctly. Now in order to do that what I would do is I'd come up to edit under plugins. If you
search for Python you're going to see that there are a number of different Python libraries here.
Now we have in this version Python editor scripting plugin turned on and it should be
turned on if you're using the project. We also have the sequencer scripting turned on here
but there are a number of other ones. We have the Python Foundation packages. This is a Python
which will just include a couple of the libraries NumPy PyTorch so that you can access them in the
path easily. Also Python automation testing. I haven't really had a chance to play with that
too much. The other one is geometry scripting here which we're not going to use but you may
want to turn on because all this is going to allow you to do is query and edit meshes from
within Python. Now this is displaying just the Python plugins that we have available.
However these aren't necessarily going to give you all the code. Now since the Python
Unreal library is generated from the back of the code if you turn on and off more plugins
anything that would be marked as blueprint editable and is something to be used within
the editor scripting you usually you're going to be able to access via Python.
So don't limit yourself to these plugins just because they have Python written on them.
All the plugins may help you out in this in this setup. Okay so that is the Python ones.
If you don't have these switched on you might want to switch them on at this point.
Now that's going to be all I think we need to look at before we start using Python. So thank
you very much that's the end of this video on setup. Next up we're going to start looking
at the different integration methods for Python.